on the picket line in Coventry workers
think you can get anything at Amazon
except a decent pay deal they're
striking they say just to make ends meet
why are you striking because uh we are
not paying usually working I work hard
but you're not paying so we need more
money but the moment we are struggling
with our life so we are struggling with
the family with the everything going
high so we want a better place is your
mortgage getting more expensive too yes
yes it is double
wow what's happening here at Amazon is
being repeated across the country now
not everybody's on strike but workers
are pushing employers with higher wages
to keep up with the cost of living in
employers facing a worker shortage and
struggling to recruit and retain staff
and paying up to make sure they have the
people they need to do the job the
result is average earnings Rising by 7.3
percent in the three months to May a
record level despite unemployment also
going up the chancellor and governor of
the bank of England say that's fueling
inflation but wages are still not
keeping up with prices rising at eight
point seven percent if growth took off
it would help bring inflation back down
to earth
but for that Britain needs to address a
worker shortage these Midland school
children maybe the engine is the future
but potential employers say they need
staff now we've got a very um aggressive
growth plan we're planning to double our
turnover within about three to four
years we've got the equipment we've got
the space we've got the capsule it's the
people that it's a critical bit now
Recruitment and attraction is in our top
three issues at the moment
um and we have to work twice as hard for
twice as long to recruit half the people
with interest rates set to rise further
a mortgage rates at a 15-year High
higher even than after Liz truss is
disastrous mini budget there's likely
more turbulence ahead Paul Kelso Sky
News in Coventry